he came out the he came out the laund
building with a door with the windows
open he came out the he couldn't have
came out there cuz we cleared that no
one was in there no he came out of there
I'm telling y'all he really did I
watched where did he go dear where did
he he he stood by the laundry door with
the little boy in his hand did you see
where he where he walked off to no all
all I seen was him standing there with
with the little boy in his hand that's
all I seen and I think he did come out
that building cuz he cuz he came out
there with the little boy in his hand
the little boy was like this just
sitting there landing and that was after
we left yes no some of y'all was still
out here when I walked in it was maybe
about like 9:20 9:25 SW meeting was over
yes the swap was over and she was like
Auntie Kim I think he surrendered
himself I said why why you say that she
said because he came out holding a
little boy with his arms up and that's
what she told me what she just said
basically the same thing to y' and this
was that 922 but now y telling
me what is that but it's it's a it's a
laundry room over
here all right I know
exactly bu
occupants the 1307
silvin come out one at a time with your
hands up this is the a police
department all right got a couple adults
in the living room there's a kid hey
come on out bring the kids
out they have cover the door has to be
open with
Vice one at a time get the kids out
bring your kids
get the kids out let's go come
on all the
children elor come
here come here
sweetie come here baby it's okay it's
okay I know we
just no no no no that's my buddy time
please except for the children one time
behind Cruiser
guys hey is that everybody yeah hey
don't let him go with the cigarette
don't let him go not that one the other
one just by we have them yeah we got
them hey SE Police
Department come on out with your hands
up hey
you is the police department come out
with your hands up and you will not be
har Sean back of police department all
right come on buddy I got him I got him
I got okay buddy come on out buddy come
on out buddy watch watch come on out
buddy John Zack Police
Department we're not going anywhere man
let's go come on out with your hands up
at
now he came out from that back uh toward
the hallway towards the left
the sometimes this can
help
Sean come on out man we know you're
here
no we
don't yeah I talk to him first hey
Sean hey man come on out we know you're
here okay your mom is out here man she
I'll let you talk to her after you come
on
out you cooperate with us you can talk
to your mother once you come out okay
thanks
how you doing Brave man give me
Knuckles yeah oh we miss you Miss there
you go tried to break it on the first
one thanks for thanks for not busting my
hand
up oh yeah I need to get in the stuff
and you can get a new battery yeah you
guys are off to tomorrow
right did you let them use the lights
yet most of your lights they're all
that's
so we're trying to uh get 15 from the
for man come on
out you have anything on you that they
miss kniv guns drugs needles anything
like that I do got to go through all
your pockets all right going go up
here
spray your feet for Maan do have that
Heat Going it'll get better after we get
in the vehicle though
okay anything I missed open your hands
for me
um I'm going switch handcuffs man it's
going to be real uncomfortable at first
cuz first set going to come off
downside
[Music]
is watch your hand
man'll feel better
man
I got double lock those
Sean another thing open your
mouth all right step on up man should be
a relatively short drive all right watch
your step Ah that's fucking my
what's
up um I don't know you said something
about get my mom my mom stays next stre
over it she get her phone number on
piece paper you have the number
memorized no she stay right here though
we guys to the county that's why I'm
personing that I need what what
apartment number is you in 9 2
N 926 926 svin no it's Barbara 926
Barbara yes Louis ghost all right we'll
see if we get please
please write a piece of paper I mean
problem step on down man watch your step
okay all
right
man what's up my rib your rib fucking
crack come on step on
up my face fuck look
think that little
C what's that man is yeah it's real warm
did uh that that heat feel good in there
yeah so dude I tried to talk to you for
an
hour you didn't come
out the guy that was out there talking
to
you I know you heard me no honestly I
didn't Hest the god to
me out at the
house where BR yeah no you didn't hear
me
talking I was out what's that I was out
you were out I was I
was was that 1497
1497 dude I was I was trying to talk to
you for an hour really yeah I was at
like five coverage dude I was trash so
when I said numerous times I'm like Sean
this David with a
police we're not going to
leave we know you're here come on out
with your hands up I I was I the days I
was dreaming that talking me
but
yeah yes I'm ask
question
okay
no try to beat my ass
the police okay fight with they try to a
fight with me but I'm comping they F
fuck me no my ribs hurt really bad but I
don't want to get charg to see the
doctor though I'm just going to deal
with it I have out
anyway all right they already going
charge me
no okay fine that's fine I think my ribs
broke though but you think your rib
broke crack do
should just came out man we're on that
place for quite some
time to the hospital here's value seen
by
EMS
yeah it's a it's a very very
minor it looks like
nothing
keep it's try but it's nasty it's not NY
no that nasty nasty nasty you touching
this whole time
man well the nurse is here to check you
out real quick all right so what
happened
buddy what happened to your
[Music]
head
okay so you don't know what happened to
your
head to
hurt
my a pund okay of laundry and a pain up
here on your
head um in our
um bottom right hand drawer should be
some normal sailing and some in there
you
get this side okay all right so your
ribs hurt lift your shirt up
back all right I'm looking everywhere
oh yeah right there yeah I see it nice
round Mar right
there okay so EMS checked you
out okay any problems in your
mouth
no all
right I don't care about you brush your
teeth
buddy I do don't don't Brea
that hurt to yeah I'm just when I push
on it I'm just asking you I mean you've
got like um red spark red Parts on your
tattoos so I'm just making sure
that well I'm checking your bones is
what I'm checking okay so I want to make
sure
that you
know I'm just doing a thorough check
onbody okay
that's where the pain is right there
yeah okay
so here's the deal for you okay um I'm
going wait till she comes back with this
I'm going to clean your face up a little
bit but um I'm going to have you um go
to the hospital or whatever get checked
out
um well make sure you tell the hospital
when you go there to um you know where
your all your pain is and if you're
having that pain in your ribs you make
sure you get that checked okay because
that you know kidneys back there and
everything else so
you it's going to hurt a little bit I
apologize I'm not a gentle person just
you know it's fine well I have to clean
it off real bit just to see what we got
going on but you know anytime anybody
complains of any head injuries or
anything like that we have to have you
checked out because I don't want there
to be any internal bleeding or anything
like that plus I want to find out what's
going on with your head and bleeding up
here
okay I'm
sorry well I mean there is a
cut
so I'm just getting blood off the face
right now so I want to see if there's on
you besides the one on your
head plus you don't need all this blood
on you okay so there is a cut up there
on your head you take care of that as
well I don't think you need any stitches
but I don't maybe one maybe not um but
anyway we'll uh go to the hospital okay
so you got gloves on you can see there
little pressure I'm just going to go get
the paper for this gentlemen
[Music]
okay I'm a
NSE
[Music]
I'm just trying to decide which hospital
is faster Sean which hospital you want
to go to hacker general or uh
Suma try to go there that's what I was
thinking but it all vary
some
I still have
cber all
right man all right all right thanks
we'll be back here in a little while yep
watch what step
dude step on down
man right I'll get that heat rolling
when we get moving
okay all right step on up watch your
step watch your head okay
good